one of the things i've talked about with
you guys over the years is
not unique to the united states but it's
particularly bad in the united states
which is when you have the degree of
connections between media figures who
are ostensibly journalists or reporters
or supposed to be people that are
sort of critically analyzing and talking
to you about what government is doing
when you have those media people
so closely tied in with friendly with
involved with whatever the very people
in government that they're supposed to
be covering you don't really get
journalism by definition or in any real
sense of the word and one of the things
that we've seen over time
uh partic over the last year since the
january six trump riots
is the degree to which right-wing media
like fox news and others are so
connected we're so connected to the
trump administration we've learned about
these text messages that were exchanged
between sean hannity and mark meadows
and others in the aftermath of the trump
riots about how best to manage it and
how this is a bad thing and trump's got
to stop talking about the stolen
election but then he would go on the air
and he would support the trump narrative
and do something totally different and
part of what goes on and i've talked
about this before because i've been in
some of these circles uh before on the
periphery
is
people don't want to lose access and
that influences a lot of how media
behaves they become
an acquaintance of someone in power
they start to get access to them and
next thing you're you know you're maria
bartoromo who has a direct line to trump
and nods along to any insane notion that
he mentioned so that's one piece of it
that we don't want to lose access part
the other part of it is how they're
actually in some cases is almost no
daylight between the media and the
government piece and there's now an
explosive new report with another little
chapter in that sean hannity fox news
propagandist
sent trump's former white house press
secretary kaylee mcinanni a post-riot
playbook
according to newly released texts
fox news's sean hannity reports huffpost
sent kaylee mcinanni a plan
to handle trump the day after the deadly
capital riot according to new newly
released text messages
hannity messaged mcinanney on january
7th with a quote five-point approach for
conversations with trump
hannity was telling mcinannie how to
manage trump
according to a letter that the white
house that the house committee
investigating the riots released on
thursday
the first two items on hannity's plan of
action read
no more stolen election talk again this
is this is a trend hannity recognized
that the stolen election talk was not
helping trump
two yes impeachment and 25th amendment
are real and many people will quit so it
seems like hannity is telling mcinanny
say to trump you could be impeached
the 25th amendment could be used
your allies will quit if that happened
sort of like to warn trump and the
letter didn't reveal points three four
and five and mcinney responded in those
text messages love that
thank you that is the playbook i will
help reinforce
hannity told makanani it was quote key
that quote no more crazy people were
allowed to access the then president
mcinanny responded yes 100 percent
mac and nanny days uh uh in the days
after the election
remember that makanani appeared with
those crazy people sidney pat i'm trying
to think i believe there was one
particular press conference
and i don't know if it's the one where
rudy's face melted i don't
know it's all kind of a blur but
mackinani appeared remember in her role
as
a trump campaign staffer not as the
press secretary alongside some
combination of sydney powell
jenna ellis
and or rudy giuliani and yet
mcinanny knew and agreed that these are
crazy people around the president so
there's three four five different
important layers here one is
this cozy relationship between fox and
the trump administration wasn't serving
anybody you had people at fox and people
around trump who knew how insane this
all was i mean listen quite frankly
we now have text messages that show us
kaylee and hannity both thought
there were crazy people around trump
giving him bad ideas
the stolen election talk was a bad idea
and yet they both went out and
reinforced it showing that this was not
them behaving on principle this was them
behaving on call it self-preservation
for mackinani call it ratings for
hannity maintaining access to trump
whatever so that's one aspect of this
and then of course number two
that
nobody is better off when you have this
journalism is not better off the
american people are not more informed
uh the people running government are not
running government in a way that is
better for the people um
everybody loses in these situations and
i know that there will be there will be
people who say well you know
chris cuomo seemed to be pretty friendly
with hillary clinton back in 2016. they
clearly know each other
yes they clearly have the clintons and
the cuomos clearly seem to know each
other
but there was not this operationally
indistinguishable
uh
relationship that was going on when it
came to governance and it just doesn't
it seems like such a
lame comparison when you now see the
connections between fox and the trump
administration so here's just you know
the text message is just another example
one of our sponsors is kamikoto who
creates elegant high-end japanese steel
kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from honshu japan
i'm a huge fan of japanese kitchen
knives i've owned a bunch of different
sets none as nice as my kamikodo knives
made with real japanese steel
every knife comes in a beautiful heavy
duty ash wood box and a lifetime
guarantee you can get them in several
different sets and combinations kamikoto
makes it really easy to figure out which
one is best for you you can also pick up
one of kamikoto's sharpening wet stones
which are designed especially for
kamikodo knives i've had an excellent
experience using kamikodo knives in my
kitchen at home it just feels
comfortable in your hand the mechanics
of slicing with high quality japanese
knives like these feel really really
nice and right now kamikoto is having a
huge valentine's day sale you get 50 off
on top of their other offers when you go
to kamikodo.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below